we're gonna kick it off by tackling
um a topic that i am truly
fascinated with and it's dating
because i am convinced that no matter
what
in life you are contending
and wrestling with and finessing and
working through
a relationship i don't care who it's
with you're in a relationship with
something it could be your dog your
grandmother your sister your mother your
brother your best friend your husband
your wife
we're best we're all trying to figure
out
uh or multiple relationships and
when it comes to dating um i
feel that behavior is really become my
number one
thing that i like to dissect and discuss
so
is anyone here dating this situation
anyone dating in the wall
uh marina hi
marina so i am in a long-distance
relationship
um my boyfriend lives in england and i
live in florida
it's incredibly difficult not only the
time difference
the time that we've been apart and
uh we have no idea when we're going to
see each other next
how long have you been dating we have
been together
for about a year and what is your
end game i mean we've talked about a
life together
um it's incredibly you know difficult
especially right now
because we just have no clue what's
going on um also we're kind of in a
challenging profession um we both we met
working on a cruise ship
so we both work on cruise ships um with
our contract lengths
and uh you know sometimes i'm on one
side of the world and he's on the other
side of the world
and so that makes it even more
challenging
okay so maybe when your industry resumes
life resumes for all of us so right now
you are in a purgatory that you cannot
control
here is the good news is usually
in normal times i'm like long distance
great it'll last that much longer
because when you're in each other's
faces 24
7 it's not good um
that said when you want to build a life
with someone i believe down the road
concessions and you know geography and
things will have to get sorted out
but since none of that is within your
control right now
make this the most romantic time write
letters
find new ways of communicating learn
more about each other in inventive sexy
cool fun ways say we're going to make
this time
count in a way it never could have
otherwise
and then when things go back to us
different kind of normal
we'll figure out what we can do then and
take each step as it comes
but for now i say go for it and figure
out every single
new unique way that you two can stay
connected
and learn more about each other yeah you
know like
i love that thank you so much no good
phew
literally like find games that you can
play like
join words with friends and become
scrabble buddies online
write love letters to each other you
know send
care packages show each other
say i want you to watch this movie
tonight and then tomorrow
we'll discuss because it's one of my
favorite and i can't wait to see what
you think
get clever i love it thank you so much
and then you can say and when i do see
you you better watch out
because i'm going and attacking you
a little dangle of a promise and a
romantic
like finish is so fun um
okay so that was so fun by the way i'm
not kidding i could do this
all day long i love talking about
relationships and no matter what your
age or situation
dating can always be a challenge i mean
look at you know
what they're going through due to
geography and covet and everything
everybody has challenges in
relationships
and we found some people who are in the
midst of struggling through their dating
experience and need some help
well we have certified dating coach and
relationship
expert and very good friend of the show
demona hoffman here
to set them up for success this is
drew's
love vlog hi jamona
hey good to see you again drew demona
you changed my life when you said
like drop the digital hankie i i mean i
just
i'm so glad that we're in this together
and i really like
talking about dating advice with you
because you have a calm and a confidence
that i really think people can benefit
from thank you we have to keep calm
and carry on and everybody still needs
love especially in today's world so
let's help some folks out well when you
equate modern romance to dropping the
digital hankie i was like yes that is
jane austen meets tinder so
katie here is a familiar experience she
has a dating
burnout situation hi katie how are you
hi drew i'm good i'm so excited to be
here hi demona
hello katie we're so excited that you're
here
please ask guru demona a question
okay guru demona um i have very little
patience after i go on a
or when i'm on a date if it's not
working or it's like
not clicking i'm pretty much like how
soon can i get out of this
because i know who i am i know what i
like
and men are very like take it or leave
it if i go on a date like you better be
bringing something to the table
so i kind of want to know how soon
without being cruel or hurtful can i be
like this isn't working
i'm out like it's 20 minutes too soon
i don't have i think i don't have the
emotional bandwidth to like
endure a date just to be polite
you know yes i do know and you do have
to conserve your emotional energy
and your time your time is really
precious so who you spend it with really
does matter
what i would say katie is i think you
might be
doing things in a reverse order you
might be skipping a really crucial
screening
step that i like to have my clients do a
video chat date or a phone call before
you even get to the date
because if you spend 15 to 20 minutes
there from the comfort of your own home
a lot of times you can see what those
red flags are you can see if you can't
really connect in real-time
communication
and you can save yourself a lot of time
by not even
going on the date do you ever do these
screening calls
no but the idea of not even having to go
so titillating i just saved you a lot of
time
and on top of that i think you should
come up with a
phrase that you always use when you
realize that it's not a match because
sometimes trying to figure out what to
say
can also eat up a lot of emotional
energy so if you just
decide you're always going to say i had
a great time getting to know you but i
don't feel like it's a match
that actually is really the most humane
thing you can do to someone so you're
not keeping them
hanging on waiting to see if you're
going to change your mind or just
waiting to get ghosted just go ahead and
close that loop
and honey you can just move on to the
next i love this demona you really are a
game changer
okay the next question we have is susan
and
susan found herself in a very
uncomfortable situation on a
video chat date funny enough uh speaking
of
susan i'm so happy you came on the show
thank you well hi drew thanks for having
me and hi dimono
so i've been dating on and off for the
last five years
and as a nana in these modern times
it's tough i recently had a nightmare
experience
where i was video chatting with a guy
who turned out to be completely
naked i couldn't get a guy to show up on
a date from a dating app so
that's something to celebrate in a very
sick way
i want a date but i also want to make
sure that my standards
boundaries and expectations are very
clear from the start
so how can i do this with these times of
dating apps
video chats and uninhibited
men
[Laughter]
oh my goodness susan that is a doozy so
first of all
i am so sorry that that happened to you
i'm sure that was really shocking and if
that ever happens to you again susan
definitely block
and and report immediately the apps take
that very seriously i hope you did that
on the last one
yeah then they won't do it to someone
else but then also i want to make sure
you're screening
going forward so if you see anyone
that is is is using sort of
uh unsavory language with language let's
say
or they're being a little too forward at
the beginning
like they're talking about your body
you're talking about what's gonna happen
when you meet up that's a little too
much too soon and then i also want you
to be on the lookout for
catfish and scammers you are
unfortunately
in the prime target group for a lot of
financial scams and i don't want
that to happen to you so look out for
things that could be form letters
if they send you a message and and if
you read it
outside of the context of connection
connecting with this person
and it could be something that they
would say to anyone like oh i love you
so much
you're so beautiful i can't wait to see
you that person could be
a scammer and so you want to make sure
that that you're
you're filtering before you you get in
that situation that's
very good information
[Music]